before we get into the crazy chaos with
the boys you're listening to fighter
and the kids few housekeeping notes for
you guys
chappelle lacy's in tampa this week
thursday friday
saturday sunday go to chapellelacie.com
get tickets to one of the funniest dudes
in the business i love that dude
he's hilarious he's my feature when i'm
on the road
go see chappelle lacy in tampa this
weekend
and then november 5th through the 7th
i'm in phoenix stand up live with these
boys and a special
guest can't wait for you guys to see the
special guests
that is phoenix uh stand up live
november 5th through the 7th
then also nashville zany's november 19th
through the 21st
same crew and also going to have a
special guest parents there nashville
zanny's t5k.com for tickets
and also soon december 5th boise i've
never been i'm excited doing a theater
there
boise you're coming up i'll have more uh
details when tickets
go live for you kids but get tickets now
for spell and myself
phoenix nashville tampa for chappelle uh
thickboy.com think boy jerseys just got
restocked get your thick asses some
jersey at thinkboy.com
thick girl restocked all our stuff so go
enjoy that thickies also speaking of
thick this episode is brought to you by
the one the only
on it on it.com fighter 10 off the
entire goddamn site what do you need man
protein powder
you need to get your brain right alpha
brain i gotcha total gut health
super important you need vitamin d3
spray i gotcha dog
what do you need you need nutrition you
need fitness mct
oil uh if you can't go to the gym let
the gym come to you
dude build your home gym with on it
kettlebells
on demand training on at six freaking
body weight training
it's streaming fitness sandbags maces
steel maces
we got star wars kettlebells we got yoga
mets battle ropes
we got freaking jiu jitsu gear we got
men's shirts women's shirts
men's tees men's shorts women's shorts
yoga gear
jiu jitsu mma gear black swan yoga we
got it all
on it.com slash fighter 10 off you're
welcome
malik what are you saying about your
sleepy day so no no no
there's this one story you told me about
where you uh
you couldn't get it up yeah i couldn't
and you you blamed it on
a weed brownie or what happened you know
what i'm talking about now is that i was
like
you suffered from erectile dysfunction
no no it was homegirl was like
aggressive with you
she was i was i don't like when they two
are me like oh come on give me this give
me this [ __ ] give me this cop
i'm like oh give me that dick yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh that dick
come on [ __ ] i'm like hold on wait
time i don't know don't do that yeah
yeah so i was like yo you know let's
just talk first
like so i was telling her like i was my
two year anniversary i was i was on the
block right
i was having problems of staying i'm
with my ex big sean right
i'm with her and i'm like yo i can't
keep like i get it up but i can't keep
it up
and i'm telling my friends i'm 25. this
is this is three years ago right
so i'm talking i'm like i go to the
block i'm telling my homies i'm like yo
listen
i can't get it up i need help bro he was
like man listen
don't you i can't go to my dad so i'm
like they was like yo listen don't worry
about that
you need a viagra pill but not any kind
of viagra pill i'm gonna take you to
7-eleven and get this black rhino oh no
she's gonna love you all
that's that john jones special that's
the job what do you mean what is that
that's that's right
he got popped for that he did are you
using that yeah who goes and uses those
john jones did really yeah and uh
obviously malik b
let me so dude i didn't know i'm 25 they
much
[ __ ] in that there's like dish soap yeah
it's a store it's a story in behind
chinese guys sweat i did
oh it is oh yeah oh it's all in there
right so i didn't know so i go to the
7-eleven i get the peel
now mind you our anniversary is tomorrow
right and i want to please her and every
time
um we get it up she like get up i just
like i have to fake an orgasm
gecko's limp yeah go limb orgasm yeah i
feel like how you did go live at 25.
well because i don't know if i wasn't
attracted to her or something but i
don't know
because you should she was hot she was
bad she was bad but you know how like
there's something going on there
i don't know jake was like nah i'm good
but it's weird oh this is a different
story i was talking about the other ones
magic right but they was like bro make
sure you eat so
like my you i picked i picked my ex
picked her up from work i'm talking cash
money [ __ ] too i'm like girl i hope you
got your handicaps sign ready cause you
ain't gonna be here walk them yeah i'm
talking about
because yeah she like all excited like
what got into you i'm like girl that's
that [ __ ] i'm like
what's about to get into you you know
what i mean i'm getting up with that
[ __ ]
right i'm giving her that good good
afternoon bro so i was like hold on so
she make dinner
she's like babe tonight's going
tomorrow's our anniversary what did she
make for dinner
she made fish potatoes and carrots i
can't forget it
that's a lot of starch and i'm ready
that's a lot of energy
okay okay you don't like
healthy
we met in the gym so we try to live our
lifestyle energy okay yeah we're some
absolutely so she made that
she made that so i'm like hold on babe i
go in the bathroom take them because
they say you gotta take it after when
your stomach is on four you can't if
it's empty
is it 30 minutes before it's 30 well
something like that right
well you need that blue
twice as fast as the pill the tools
what all that [ __ ] scares me
bro so i take the pill we about to have
sex i don't feel it i don't feel no it
didn't it don't
want to kick in i didn't know that so so
i'm like god damn what's going on
so i'm having sex the same thing so i
fake orgasm right
and she was like yo you came fast again
i'm like yeah i'm so sorry
but the next morning i'm on full
i'm a heart [ __ ] bro i'm so hard but
listen i'm so
hard i feel my heartbeat in my wrist
yeah you know what i mean like i was
like oh
and she's late for work i'm like girl
you better get your ass in his bed she
was like no so
i'm fully on hard now here's the thing i
have to go to the barber shop
i said barbershop i didn't reschedule
that i know my barber
was going out of town and i need to get
a haircut so it was like it was a do or
die situation now you just do you tape
it up top yes you know what it i tucked
it in
so i'll walk you through them you gotta
tuck them up top tuck them up top oh
come on it should it should touch your
belly button
put your dick down comfortable put the
cover over your phone okay
it's uncomfortable but i went to the
barber middle school yeah
okay black barbershop is packed that day
my appointment
i'm tucked up i'm tucked in i'm waiting
i sit down you're rock hard
i'm rock hard though yeah so i get up
the
untucked full salute it took one black
guy to say
this [ __ ] everybody started
they killed me yeah
this [ __ ] that was like hey hold
on bro we got a game
that was like what the [ __ ] bro i swear
to everybody
[Laughter]
my barber was like they was making jokes
i'm gonna give this cup but ain't gonna
be that hard
i'm gonna go damn bro they kill me just
tell them we're like nah i took a pill
they was like you taking the pill for us
you gave me that that's what they went
and like not like change not not my
channel
like they used me as an ad they was like
hey bro listen i told you you're gonna
be looking good for me and
women look look at how hard he is for
you like yo i swear to god the whole
barber shop lit me up
i've taken questions i've taken the
alice before i see what it's about and
my doctor sent to me
and then uh i saw the pill and one of my
boys uh
i won't say his name but one of my boys
is all dude yeah
i popped too dude so pop two but his
were like small milligrams
my doctor gave me like the big boys if i
was gone bigger than him i'll pop two of
these but they're the highest
dosage you can get dude first of all
didn't this way i need blue chew didn't
kick in fast enough
same thing me and my girl have sex and
then i fall asleep and i wake up
to [ __ ] horror bro y'all
it increases blood flow everywhere not
just your dick dude
my face was i was i was beat red
the veins in my neck were pulsating i'm
sweating
my heart all that just to get the dick
to stay up never again
never again never again look here's
here's the symbolic of the story
later on tonight yeah is that symbolic
of the stuff i'll follow you
follow that
so after i get lit up i'm talking about
they lit me up in the barbershop i get
my hair cut
and i you know i like black people roast
you i i turn religion sad i'm sad i was
like
so later on that night my girl's like yo
happy anniversary she gives me a wallet
and guess what she gives me a pill to
stay hard
i said girl go go ahead and cheat on me
i'll go ahead and say no more say that
no more big sean she said say let's
do this
yeah but that was the first time the
second time was with this girl uh
damn you have do you have uh erectile
dysfunction issues dude yeah do you
this is no because now now i want my
queen six figure queen
um i get up like man i don't i can't
stop getting up
like we go all day i'm talking we like
we like some animals
yeah i mean so i just i know i met the
right one but but before this girl
she was just too aggressive and i don't
like that thing
that turned me off like yeah did she
offer you candy or [ __ ] like she got
offered me like yeah listen that would
make me hurt
[Applause]
yo yeah so she offered me candy i was
like well hold on you know and i'm like
i don't really eat candy she was like
well come on i need i need to get it
like come on
pull it out she thought the candy was
gonna entice you yeah what are you
14. was it right was it right
she tried to rape me i don't i don't i
don't know what she tried to do but
well and she was just too she was just
too aggressive i was like listen stop
stop yeah and she was like what
do you like women i say yeah but not
your kind of women and she's like what
do you mean you're kind and then we got
into a whole discussion
i was like listen all right didn't she
she was flaming me and
roasting by the way yeah and she was
like yo i was like come on let's do it
and she was like okay we're kissing and
stuff like that and my you know how like
your penis no better than you
yeah he's like i'm not getting he didn't
get up i was like what's we call a
timeout
i was like it's not you it's me she was
like you know what get your ass out
there
nothing more embarrassing oh yeah she
kicked you out
no no erectile dysfunction chin you got
a problem with that
i've experienced it before yeah yeah you
know i'm an older man i know i'll tell
you the story i think i told cat but
we have to keep it between us oh yeah i
remember that okay
between don't worry nobody's listening
so i did uh i took this thing
i know he said that like that's a
disclaimer you can't tell nobody
he does he does the case of the
yeah so there's there was a girl that i
dated before yeah and then
you know what back then i used to party
a lot yeah party yeah it's a party so
i didn't know that cocaine let's just
say let's just say i took cocaine which
i'm not saying i did but i didn't know
it would affect your dick right yeah it
affects your dick
yeah so that you can't get it up right
no i mean it was like i couldn't [ __ ]
understand but it felt
really like a super horny but it felt
really good but i just couldn't get it
up
so then now i associated that whenever
we try to have sex again i associated
that time with her
so i would have trouble getting up with
her came over for a little while yeah
because if my brain was associating that
yeah it was a mental thing oh
yeah i think it's just totally mental
blue balls
no i don't know if i got bloop i was
super horny so i gotta say because you
know you get all riled up
yeah you can't get it up but you just
got blue balls and [ __ ] yeah but it's
not working like your brain
yeah once it didn't work that's all i
could think about i was so
freaking out you don't need to stop
taking stuff hey but then
but then but then when you wanna when
you go to have sex it's
so stressful exactly that's all you're
thinking about and that's the worst come
on dude that's it
like i get in the bathroom i slap
business i slapped him
yep i talked to him i was like listen
we've been together
all our life i know all right i had your
yeah exactly what are y'all doing to
y'all ding-a-ling
bro i'll slap his ass up
he'll get a real beat down and perform i
talk like michael jackson's dad i'll
beat the [ __ ]
ain't gonna perform i beat the [ __ ] up i
didn't get it up and
i put these dick beaters on him man hell
yeah yeah y'all crazy yeah bro
crazy [ __ ] you your hand turned that
shake weight in your mind you better get
your
yeah yeah oh i'm sorry chappelle never
had
any debt problems i mean i didn't know
people just
naturally had dick problems yeah why why
think so many people buy viagra and
[ __ ] blue chew man that business is
so crazy
first of all this just scares me because
like it gets your heart rate
like i you know i got high blood
pressure yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't [ __ ] around you know that's why
it's illegal like in sports you can't
take vaga or bluetooth because
it does increase your cardiovascular
that's what i'm saying that's
an illegal substance yeah i don't like
to take anything [ __ ] nyquil freaks
me out
you know microsoft i just see that cause
it's a terrible thing that's [ __ ] like
that girl's so bad for you
it's not yeah are you ever taking it you
have you taken it before when i have
headaches
you take it for a headache well what
that's something we want to take nyquil
for
yeah that girl's nasty yeah you know you
don't mess with anything huh no
i mean like i said i'll smoke a joint
i'm on all sorts of that
yeah nicotine kratom if you had a little
drug
try vitamin d vitamin d vitamin d yeah
vitamin c
uh well yeah it's in like my
multivitamin but oh i do like the
fiber forty percent yeah dude this is a
blue chew read check it out
forty percent of men by age 40 struggle
with
uh erectile dysfunction how crazy is
that 40 percent well they need to judge
it off based on when you lost your
virginity
right i don't think so because i lost
mine at 21.
a little late in the game a little late
in the game but still it don't have
a girl i met at applebee's she was a
waitress at applebee's she was not
that's
just sitting at the bar that's when you
picked her up oh well she picked me
up older orderly
older lady no no no i think we might
have been the same age really
and she picked you up yeah because i was
like oh hey how you doing
really yeah nice to meet you and then
you just went to the crib
i was actually at my brother's house she
lived in the same
complex as my brother white girl yeah
she was she was looking in a lichen and
then took you back to the place she
wanted that bbc
yeah and yeah uh she remembered bm's i
remember uh
yeah she got me drunk because i was like
oh no i'll just go home she's like no
take some shots take some shots
oh i was like ah you know i'll just go
home i was so like
you know i wasn't i was a nerd yeah
you're like i'm good
yeah i was like no i'm good my brother's
like
he threw a magnum i remember i never get
he threw a magnum at my face i was like
oh okay
and it landed right on my shoulder with
her sitting right next to me and she
knew what was going on oh yeah yeah yeah
and was it a good experience she's the
first times a little i couldn't finish i
was so drunk
oh wow i remember mean girls was playing
in the background which is one of my
favorites
i love lizzie lohan yeah she was tall
too yeah she stood up for mine
she stood up from the bar and like was
tall the girl yeah she was tall
yeah big brother mm-hmm so
but you you you were too drunk though oh
too drunk i remember i walked her home i
still had the condom on
oh yeah i had no clue what the [ __ ] was
going on
she was like what are you thinking about
i was like i don't know my mind's blank
i remember uh you lost your virginity no
i remember
uh sixteen had a serious girlfriend
serious girlfriend
oh so yeah normal [ __ ] um but
i did it 16 no i lost i think 21 is the
best age
hell no 14 for me i lost it to us yeah
well if you watch 16 and pregnant like
jesus christ
though yeah oh but there's these
brazilians used to fly and train with us
uh in denver when i was fighting and i
remember this brazilian hooked up with
just like you know kind of the [ __ ] of
the town
and uh the next one he's talking about
i'm like did you use protection he goes
oh no he's broken english i want to try
and do he goes oh no i'm fine dude
because after i have sex i i wash it off
my dick with soap i'm like
oh no it's going to work like that
that's cool man
oh it's that third world country [ __ ]
you ever caught one
no committee of hell yeah twice you
caught it yeah yeah twice
oof twice twice yeah for real i didn't
know i had it the second time
well y'all wow i didn't know i was like
you had that runny dick yeah i was like
hold on something something ain't
shooting out right
i was like yeah all right that was like
how long you had it for i was like well
[ __ ] you tell me
when though i went to the doctor you
have to go and they have to take the
q-tip and put in your
yeah because that's what they have to do
no no they didn't man they gave me two
of them they just looked at it when yeah
yeah they're there's already no they're
familiar with this territory they gave
me two pills take this
and uh drink this water and that's it
though that's it at the end of the world
yeah i heard they have the yeah jabba i
think that's what i think that's for
herpes though
no is it no that's for any std they
usually take a q-tip and put it right
down your pee hole
yeah what do they do for women i think
same thing but with your vagina
oh really still q-tip but it's just like
yeah it's just a swab
it's not it's probably not even painful
it's not yeah for dudes
but that was that was that was my dark
days though yeah see now you see
this man this is firing the kids after
was your brother proud of you oh yeah
cause it was so funny we were driving to
applebee's that night that's where my
brother and i used to
get [ __ ] up applebee's yeah you know
the bar now yeah i guess a heavy hour at
like 10 the
drinks were cheap and [ __ ] but he was
like man you got to have sex
dawg you got to do this [ __ ] i'm like
how much older is he than you
my brother was two years older than me
oh so you guys were close oh yeah yeah
we were super close a lot of people
was like man you got to do this [ __ ] man
i was like it don't happen when it
happens you know i'm not
going to you know i'm not going to go
out there and just you know
yeah throw it out there yeah i'm not
going for this exactly what i said to
him he's like man you gotta like
you gotta go for it yeah and then that
happened that night and
and and i remember she was like you
should take some shots you stay the
night
and i was like oh no i just live right
down the street you know i you know i
only had one beer
no no take some shots and my brother's
like yo drink a little bit you know
drink
he knew what was up oh he knew what was
up and then he was like oh i gotta go to
my friend's house
grab something he [ __ ] just took it
was he a ladies man oh hell yeah he was
yeah he knows what that oh yeah he knew
what was up he was
i'll be right back i know yeah well
exactly
like because when he was walking out
that's when he threw the condom
he's like i'll be right back and it was
just like what a great guy
oh he was a great guy he was a gee that
was a good aim too right
now oh yeah he just that's that man he
throws i was like uh you don't need that
did he uh have a drinking problem like
you did like were you guys drinking
partners in crime
oh yeah yeah we both had the drink yeah
oh we both would go
super hard but especially together man
together it's trouble oh
[ __ ] yeah we've gotten in fights he
broke my guitar
[ __ ] yeah still mad at that but uh
[Laughter]
malik doesn't know his brother passed
away you know
oh yeah my brother oh my
that's cool up there right now
right now you got the z hanging he can
fix this
i thought he was joking but he's really
like
oh he got here before us
one of the things that this was always
happened to us at a club
where girls just loved us sandwiching
them like on the dance floor the two
leathers were too sick but he was bigger
than me
wow oh he was way following me yeah and
and also like yeah he's like he was like
six two big dude oh he was a big dude
he played football and [ __ ] oh damn and
you guys what did they say white chicks
he was number
number i know the numbers go for certain
positions right yeah
so he was number if you just told me the
number i'll know what position he played
i think he was 70. so he was offense
aligner defensively you don't know what
that is
he was offensive oh sorry he was 71. so
he was probably offensive line
oh yeah 71 yeah he's a big dude you see
her brother
and she's way bigger than me bro so you
guys would sandwich white girls
but then white girl come on
come on my brother he was like he
[ __ ] went for
man he picked up a girl at 7-eleven one
time jungle figure damn
yeah he was dude he was girls so when
you guys got together
because you guys were partners in crime
drinking was it
while he was alive were you like okay
i'm gonna check in rehab or get better
no no none of us there was never any
talk
no when you know actually when i started
going to anger management
um i started talking to him about it
and stuff and he he got better he got
better i think he just had a knight
yeah well that's what yeah that's what
they said it was an accidental overdose
yeah he just had a knife
fentanyl or something if you don't want
to talk about you don't have to i don't
know i don't mind at all
i'm good you know was it was it fentanyl
because that seems like to be
[ __ ] people no it was i i think yeah
what they had found in the system they
didn't find
it wasn't fentanyl because he was sober
for a while right
yeah he wasn't like he was sober he was
just you know he worked for uh
he was taking it easy yeah he just he
just had it i think he just took
an amount that he would normally take if
he was back in the heyday
back in the heyday yeah and that's what
got him [ __ ]
such a shame oh yeah it was it was i
mean it was devastating but
you know like i mean my life now is just
like
it's forced me to like because you know
i felt like my brother was like my
protector yes you know but like now
life has kind of like forced me to like
you know build this
uh individual strength you know since
since that like i've learned to like
take that um
you know into consideration like it's
just kind of like
oh here's this gift of like you know
you're gonna
be strong for yourself now yeah you have
to yeah oh yeah you have to 100
it's like the the [ __ ] you also have
a good like uh
networking two of friends who care about
you oh yeah yeah and i think that's
because
you know a lot of that is because i
changed the my energy
you know what i mean the energy i was
putting out there before you know i had
friends that
weren't necessarily you know the best
people to be or
yeah good does that make sense yeah you
know and then once you change that
energy up of what you're putting out
there
you know shit's different you know i bet
your brother now is looking out for him
like this [ __ ]
yeah look at him going i know he was
gonna get him going
you know i always think about this the
funniest thing about
my brother dying and not that it's funny
but the funniest thing
is the [ __ ] people that reach out to
you and try to like
comfort you and they don't necessarily
you know people don't know how to
comfort
another person when they're dead no so
people would send me pictures
of my brother photoshopped in the clouds
oh my god
like a skating rink and it was like the
most brutal
[ __ ] like like a hoodie hey that
here's this one hey that's more of a
black person thing right about to say
the one of him in the clouds he looked
like a ghetto astronaut bruh it was so
[ __ ] up
you'll see what you'll see with like
nipsey with like nipsy there's so many
but they had wings on there there were
so many like wings
spray painted shirts yeah
oh my gosh that's the [ __ ] i kept
getting i was like because photoshop was
like
you know really popping people everybody
was getting it everybody thought they
had photoshop skills they thought they
were so they were
they thought they were helping me out i
was like brother son [ __ ] help me
guys
i hate that [ __ ] dude man this is
ridiculous that's like my problem in
louisiana was
you you didn't you didn't start doing uh
comedy while your brother was alive did
you
oh i did dude so i started comedy in
2010
but when he died i stopped
i just [ __ ] she probably didn't feel
funny oh no dude
no yeah and like you know you know shout
out to
shout out to jason collings and uh brent
morin they were the ones that like
guys they were the ones that got me back
up how's that you know
well they didn't no one knew that i was
depressed
you know really yeah i mean well i don't
know
actually no one said anything but yeah
people probably did but they probably
didn't know what to say to me yeah
but um you know they came to town they
were doing tempi improv
and uh you know uh
jason jason i just that was my first
time meeting brent
but jason i already had known that i met
jason through dalia
and so jason was like yo chappelle's
pretty funny throw him up
and then all of a sudden brent comes up
to me he was like yo you're going up
tonight
doing a guest spot and i hadn't done it
in like how long
two years oh damn like yeah like a good
solid set yeah it's been a minute
and so uh and that is what man and when
i uh that was 2016.
oh [ __ ] so my brother died 2013. okay
and so uh i was still trying to do it
you know but i just wasn't
you know feeling it and then uh 2016
rolled around
and that's when and i would just go hang
you know at the comedy club still
that's pretty decent dude when you think
about that's only four years ago
yeah literally four i've been in bed
because i'm back here for phoenix yeah
you met me the same year i got back up
is with the year i met you
crazy yeah cause then you opened for me
and brian right
uh no i thought yeah yo but you oh you
were back there
i was back there that's right michael
joe michael yo
yo was the show before us the show
before that's right yeah you were that
you were in the green room
yes that's right and that's how i met
you guys that's right yeah
and then um yeah once i got back in it
because that was the first time i talked
about real [ __ ]
yeah which which the audience can sniff
out oh dude yeah i talked about like
like beforehand i was just saying [ __ ]
just to say [ __ ] because
i'm like oh this is like a funny thing
but you don't have perspective
yeah i don't have anything like that
it's [ __ ] yeah and then um
you know i think it was the quitting the
drinking that gave me the clarity
and like it forces you to force me
you know to like
understand what it is to be like alone
and that being alone
sometimes isn't like a bad thing no it's
okay to be able to
learn a lot alone yeah it's like this
comfort you know what i mean and all of
a sudden like
once you understand that you just
deliver a better self
sure to people you know what i mean like
i think about that
so that's like what you know there was
just so much along the way that
really and then all of a sudden all
these things just started happening
starting
dude yeah bill burr i met him at the
hotel i was
you know helping him with his luggage
and then
you know he was like are you funny and i
was like oh yeah
and then he was like he goes well won't
you come by let's let's see what you
could do
and then he threw me up i was just i was
literally helping do with his luggage
that's cool marking his car and [ __ ]
you know yeah all these things just
started like i met you guys
yep you know i met this [ __ ]
then he came out here then i came out
here and just started like [ __ ]
rolling moved out here and then
yeah man now look at you now look at me
i don't take dick pills
you don't need them i don't need dick
pills you know who i i was with uh
stevo yesterday he's gonna do a uh guest
spot when we're in phoenix he's gonna
drive he's going to come out
dude that's love love that dude i love
him yeah that was such
that was like i don't like there's a fan
boy that was
oh that was a big fan boy i love a good
triumph story
what did you say i could tell in your
eyes oh you could tell them
i admire him so much because i love a
good triumph story
like that he had it i geeked out over
that stuff like he had it bad that's
what i'm saying like
when he brought up like alcohol
addiction drug addiction
sex addiction like all these addictions
and to see where
dude is that like i look up to that like
that's the stuff that like
i feel gets me yeah because i've been
watching them since i was a kid
i know we all have arizona they started
yeah jackass was was like oh all my
friends thought
they were [ __ ] so huge yeah and now
they're doing that uh
the fourth movie they're because that's
why he i was like
because we're talking about stamp he's
like man i haven't been on the road a
while ago come to a spot in phoenix he's
like
i'd love to amazing let me check my
schedule because we're finishing
uh his podcast but no i was doing his
podcast yesterday
he does an rv drove up to my house crazy
so [ __ ] funny yeah
so cool so funny so uh he's like uh
we're finishing uh jackass the movie let
me see
he's like oh [ __ ] i got that weekend off
he's like i'm there brother you know
[ __ ] here we go hell yeah it's gonna be
dope maybe he and i can do backflips on
stage
i know standing backflip yeah you
you know it's a clown school or
something i was gonna say you know st
like what people don't realize is stevo
yeah
going to clown school circus right he's
an
illustrator
he knows what he's doing yeah he's great
man what can you do malik
uh that's a great question but let me
see this
guy backflip while he's on fire
from that youtube channel slow-mo guys
hello the internet welcome to this
slow-mo guys hello internet
look at him i hope he doesn't mind i've
stepped into his jacket
i'm stevo insanely jealous of your guys
balloons popping in slow motion
he is he's so [ __ ] wild i love him
we're cause he's trained
wait what
are they slow motioned it was that's
[ __ ] hilarious
dude oh oh
oh that looks cool
too he didn't landed that i know that'd
have been hard he didn't move his
his turnover was that fast yeah ooh he
almost landed though he almost landed
if he would have just pulled his feet a
little bit quicker do you remember that
sorry look at me [ __ ] coaching steve
don't worry about that that's what we're
doing now that fat kid on the scooter
i never forget right now i just keep
getting tagged and
fat kid [ __ ] that's not you know i
respect it i'm thick
and fat is dope by the way okay what's
he trying to do kick it
oh he's trying to pop the balloon yeah
yeah
that is insane pull those toes he's got
it a little bit
holy [ __ ] he did it did he land oh i
think he landed he landed it oh
look at that is he on fire oh that's
hard that's perfect
it was perfect yeah yeah i missed your
balloon
damn all right what's the point oh they
try and put some
flames on there i don't roll like that
man i i i don't
thought before is that [ __ ] supposed to
go in your mouth
it's not supposed to go in your throat
you're supposed to swallow it
see that'd be hard right dude i can't
even smoke cigars can you smoke a cigar
no not really i'm not sucking it i'm not
a big cigar guy it is so [ __ ] hard
i i can't even really smoke weed i'm not
good with any of that you're not getting
any smoke i don't do well with
hmm this is him like doing it again yeah
looks like a different
day too man he really got up he's he's
like dead he caught some air
steve was a talented dude he is dude
did you watch his special no i didn't
you're fun man oh yeah
yeah he's dude look at him what a
gangster wow
look at him yeah because of stevo after
that
that was dope that was hard because if
you watch stevo's special you just like
lean up doing all this stuff like he
gets
the dopest footage like the way it shot
yeah everything
like it's such a spectacle i was like i
need to step up my [ __ ] like camera
game
yeah so that dude from dallas peter i
hired he's gonna be on the road with us
now
oh i'm gonna shoot a bunch of like dope
footage of us on the road and then
probably december january we released
like 15 to 20 minutes of stand up
damn yeah you gotta let them know yes
devo inspired it
when's your birthday january 23rd uh
it's a little late but we could
well you can do it on my birthday
december 23rd i feel like that's oh
that's a gift
we're a month away we might be out in uh
boise december 5th
oh okay okay the fifth of december is
really dope isn't it a dope day isn't
there something on that day oh it's
lebron birthday no lebron
saturday he's right here oh is it gonna
be snow
i'm thinking of jay-z it should be in
idaho
oh in december yeah there's gonna be
snow like i never seen snow
you never seen snow snow it's time you
never seen snow nah it's cool to see
once saturday it's a [ __ ] oh dude i
was in i where was i
i was in check weather in december
edmonton back in november at the house
of comedy
it was negative oh my god you got a ball
in that weird hotel in canada yes it was
a nightmare snow galore and i didn't
have
snow boots or anything like that so i'm
just walking in the snow in my cortez
[ __ ] up no boo snowing on them
timberlands right what's that oh but
then the six is sunny
it looks like that can i get some dope
coats
dude first time uh i did buffalo helium
one of my favorite clubs
shout out i flew out there in the snow
was
so bad i called my uh agent i'm like
dude i should probably cancel the shows
man that's the blizzard
and he's like no dude they live in
buffalo they don't give a [ __ ] i'm like
dude yeah i was like dude i'm gonna sell
seven tickets like no dude you're almost
sold out i'm like yeah but they're not
gonna show up dude i go dude
there's seven foot i cannot walk out of
my hotel he goes
find a way to get there man they're
gonna show up dude i get there
they these [ __ ] came on snowmobiles
[ __ ]
yeah they don't care the snow shoes they
show up
giant parkas on didn't give a [ __ ] dude
that was
what they do it was such a dope club
yeah they're just so hard to get to it's
such a dope club
and then the you know the buffalo
chicken wings started there so went to
the original buffalo place me and jay
eight
five thousand wings me and jason you get
oh i love wings you like wings yeah you
know what
i'm gonna tell you something i used to
be a boneless guy
you're not traditionally hey you
traditionally you should be great all
right okay come back
you vote
yeah i realized oh i was disrespecting
wings
i was disrespecting the [ __ ] out of
wings by eating boneless it's cause
applebee's
they got the bonus that's why i was
addicted to the [ __ ] bubbles
you didn't get the shrimp dude you don't
act like you ain't been to applebee's in
the middle of it
you know between like tji fridays
applebee's
who's your team bro tea oh chili's i
love
but dude chili's baby rack ribs holla
and a large chocolate shake
dude here's here's
when i was a kid that chocolate no don't
say it
the ribs she's like yep and the shake up
like oh we balling
she wouldn't get paid and she's like you
can order it and then what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna start the car
when the check comes you guys run
outside all right you died
all the time you didn't really oh no oh
[ __ ]
you got caught we never
tgi fridays when's the last time you've
been there magic johnson's up before
it's been a minute bro appetizer that
[ __ ] is fantastic yeah ah
still it's so unhealthy it's probably
been like i'd probably say probably
but i was gonna ask you guys about wings
and my girls eat wings like this it's
disgusting to me but you eat like the
tendons and the fat like
yeah hell yeah
ah that's disgusting it's delicious yeah
if it's cooked right never seen an asian
or a mexican need a wing i don't know
like my girl
people eat you know we have more wings
like you don't need suck it good though
it's tasty oh my god deep throat that
wing dude and just
yep she knows how to do it dude they do
a lot of korean wings
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah koreans do
chickens so good fried chicken yeah
i went out with this asian girl why did
they clap when the food come
what whether someone's brought up was
that that patrick's party started come
on
why didn't big [ __ ] clap with the
food
[Music]
like you don't need to [ __ ] pick it
apart like it's not about like eating
they like the tenderness it's like yeah
they like yeah the crunchy but
it's uh tasteful or very tasty
like flavorful yeah very flavorful more
of like a consistency thing
both bro this is what you do you order
from uh wing stop and you get them extra
crispy
wingstop gangster wing stuff you know
who owns a lot of wing stubs
yeah that's so rich lemon pepper my
wings you eat the
this is what rick this is how
influential rick ross is
they were at the magic city club in
atlanta shut up
shut up great things this is the top
strip club in the world it's like the
pro ball of strippers go there
the finest chocolate honeys in the world
are doing oh okay
i would love to go you won't know soon
dude it's fantastic
so lou williams left the bubble to eat
the wings and get his dick card
oh that's what we got in trouble this is
how great rick ross is
him his boys always chill there right
all the time and they love wings
but when you get wings there's hot sauce
on he's like dude that can't be all up
on the strippers with wing sauce yeah so
they came up with that dry lemon pepper
rub
and that's how lemon pepper wow shout
out to rick ross shout out shout out to
ricky rosie that's great yeah hell yeah
hell yeah
damn everybody goes to this place is
that great both
goes to it everyone's goes to the strip
club isaac city
just a mecca of strip clubs damn i tried
to get in there but my um
you gotta have some hard cold cash
you're gonna be pretty famous
you gotta go with your girlfriend they
don't let you just get a question my
goddamn girl
like little wings does mayweather go
there hell yes like little i
haven't like my buddy his name is bear
he's uh he's done a bunch of photography
work for me but he's little wayne's
personal
photographer in uh birdman's uh-huh and
he has a pic i wish he could po oh my
god god damn
whoa oh [ __ ]
don't you want to eat some wings when
you look at this by damn post guys so is
there like a thing with food and girls
uh stripping
what's quiet i know right that dumb
question i guess dude
how great is that though that [ __ ]
hypnotizing look
she probably number like 20 21 oh and
she's a shark and she should come on
what does that mean she's like oh mama i
fell in love with that
look how pretty she is bro a stripper
talked me out of two grand and i didn't
know how great is she wow
yeah houston two greens haven't been in
a stream savage 21 there
yeah 21 savage oh yeah when i say so
white savage 21.
what's up savage 121. yeah right um
we'll let that slide
we'll let this slide i'm going to just
say it's not past that oh but i was
telling my boy uh bear who's the
photographer a little waiting uh
cash money look he went to magic club he
has a picture
he he's like he i don't think he's
posted it hopefully you don't mind me
telling stories here's a picture like
he's like this and they made it rain so
hard
you see strippers like nose like this
standing up in the cache
and they're just like it's like it's
like strippers they're sharks
they're just in the cache like this i
love it dude last time i went to the
strip club was i think
2014 and i was sober most awkward [ __ ]
i've ever
oh it was horrible because you don't buy
the [ __ ] like hey my name's cinnamon
you're like
yeah like uh i don't like when you're
drunk it's cool cool cinnamon is that
you're just too alert when you're there
sober yeah it's not a place for a sober
person
i i beg to differ you like oh yeah
you're sober yeah
i love going i'm not different what do
you mean by that i mean
it's not a bad thing he's just different
uh someone told me and uh one of our
one of uh i forget who told us when we
were in dallas
i guess there's a bbw strip club only
big [ __ ] only they got this in the uh
they got one
it was i'm sorry malik told us yeah you
told us that
that's where you and justin go what i
know you got your mouth like that dog
say you said it all the time you said in
the whole time
airing him out on him and justin going
every friday
it's not everybody's girl i thought he's
playing pickup basketball all right
it's not every friday but it's a long
beach it's a long beach right there
shout out what's it called
uh spring uh don't
and they have so the later it goes the
bigger the woman is later goes
by two o'clock that you've seen you said
she comes out you see the one i'm i sent
you the picture of you see that one
and yeah she was she would answer that
she's not a dancer but i was like yeah
did you see the woman no she didn't want
to
introduce me but they're the size of
that woman exactly so it's how they do
it
how do they do it and no no they
probably they probably get down on them
oh i would love to go i love to go they
love babies
of course they want food what is it with
food and strip clubs
you try to chill watch some cheeks and
they had a game on you can watch the
game
at shotgun woolies in denver you get
prime rib wednesday night dog
shout out yeah watching cheat tits and
cheeks and eating your prime rib
dip it in the sauce that is a [ __ ]
craziest thing go to the room
shout out to shotgun willies but you
don't know the name of the [ __ ] fat
girl club no just type in long beach
long beach uh long beach strip club
bbw yeah bbw long beach it has to have a
cool name like
earthquakes
he's so stupid
his name like earthquake is dope that
actually sounds dope dawg you never been
to earthquakes you've been earthquakes
and big [ __ ] and you said they get a
lot of love huh bro this is one
girl oh bruh she this shout out to shout
out to the big girls man no no
oh three is it 352 no
club dude hear me out here
city oh no no no no no no but listen
like hear me at 10 a.m it was it was
heavy d she got up there
and she like bought the bruh and she was
like the favorite like she it was her
night
night like they broadcast they advertise
yeah she's that light skinned
tattoos i'm talking about
and she got up there and she climbed
that goddamn pole i was scared
everybody apparently this is her routine
she did the little two cut
and all that
it took me to the wizard of oz i was in
kansas when she didn't move
okay i was like come on i just threw out
my money it wasn't a lot but i support
it
that's all it counts come on come on bro
come on whatever i can do
right uh here's here's my idea of our
business plan the three
for bbms okay oh okay
but we're bbms yeah so what we do is
because real estate's cheap right now
because la's
terrible copy that's a nightmare here
but we could get a dope club
and we opened a heavyweight strip club
called heavyweights and we have dope ass
food for the big [ __ ] them fat dudes
the fact
that i'm like bbm's
get some big pretty girls you know what
you don't see a lot of you never see
do you see uh actually maybe you'd what
like bigger dudes would is
with a skinnier girl you know like it's
usually like it's usually big dudes with
a skinny girl yeah
i thought it was usually like skinny
dudes with bigger women man you better
look at the drug dealers you know yo
they say
it's big dudes just like fine girls come
on that's why they've got money
bro that's what a 90-day fiance fiance
the other way
no come on doug no i haven't
that's why the girls be always on
vacation never post a man
oh come on bro you gotta understand she
got a fat drug fantasy castle sounds
like i could find some heavyweights yeah
i think i'm gonna go out on the uh
i don't know it start with it all set on
your
they have they run a strict business
well i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell
you right now
you know some strip clubs and uh night
clubs
they and i've friends who work there
they would line their girls up
and they they they check their stomachs
and their cellulite on their legs and
stuff and they're too big they send them
home
no or they tell them they got to lose
weight really draw out a sexist business
which also
like if you put on some weight well i
mean like dog we're trying to
[ __ ] i mean like there was things
like with cheerleading like
you know the flyers don't take me back
do you you know the little one
the smaller girl yeah that's like a you
know you can't have love handles to be
[ __ ] doing backflips and [ __ ]
well it's just it's just what you're
talking about it's not safe
it's also it's not appealing dude we
can't have that what
uh like a bigger girl you just can't
have it yeah in the air
it's like if you're with cheerleading
the spinners right spinners
spinners flyers no spinners or something
else
right you're right what are the spinners
don't act like you don't know you don't
know where the spinner is
like on the wheel you know how you were
with that big [ __ ] you had been the
spinner
is
no you guys go ahead do your thing wait
do you hate money no i don't hate
money ballin it seems like a sketch
business
well hold on we really need somebody to
be a hard-nosed manager who's really
gonna
not let those big [ __ ] get away with
anything me that's because you give them
an inch they're gonna take up
you need a hundred when they come to the
back when they come to big women no i
know
don't give up on me i got you who do we
know who's like
we need like a bill burr like real
oh here it is here it is type in club
bounce club
oh i just i was i was on it you was on
it yeah but it was an actual club not a
strip club
so these are they turned it turns to a
strip club
and then them girls are small there's
only heavy weights in them hold on let
me tell them
the second one on the bottom row yeah no
the one the bottom row they're all lined
up
uh right there like like like they're in
uh aka
no note up above there right now yeah
look at that black girl in the end
brenda say yeah look at that
look at caboose in the back huh
everyone's in plaid
yeah this shit's dope so that's where
you hang out malik
no i don't yeah is that where you hang
it yeah you know about it well yeah
i bet it's so fun it is fun i ain't got
a lot of you it's so goddamn fun
i mean it's just women big big women are
nice that one's pretty
yeah listen ain't nothing wrong with big
women but look look when you get there
it's like it's like here's the thing
look at him see he looks like he
could manage our business that's the guy
that's this guy we need
overpriced [ __ ] waiting around man yeah
hell no he looked like mac 10
no yes he do much love to him club
bouncy bounce
yeah yeah so just big girls know to go
there though
it's safe there yeah because it's it's
it's big dudes and just like us
and they're so fun they're like hey and
they hit on you oh that sounds funny
they hit a little
clubs have genres they really do they
hit on you like different clubs have so
you can be up at the drink a big girl
come
let me buy you a drink well i never
thought you was gonna ask
there's this club back home in arizona
where it's like strictly for
like older women that like younger dudes
cougars look at here
you got that in newport beach look how
you trying to get it it's like a bar
restaurant
i think it's called blue martini or
something like that
i think i think it might be called blue
martini
yeah all right here come here
no i'm going to meet my girl i thought
she was here i got a girl man this
ghetto ass
chloe kardashian
i love you trying to slide out
i got a queen back home man that place
looks come on man look at
the hell yeah bro look at that look i
look i love that little arm that's what
i love about we should do a
uh justin undercover and put a body cam
on him why why i had to be justin i
could listen let me
you should be the [ __ ] king of the
[ __ ] yeah justin's the king of the big
you were you're right you're right i
gave that to you no i love that
it's kind of his thing you know i missed
that arm though y'all understand you
should get a little warmer
talk about those big traps that you have
yeah that let me know they can cook
they got traps yeah it's like a pig
triceps
yeah triceps i was like yeah they used
it on big tracks
they got those big triceps just hanging
off
that's just dope bounce that's that's
the that's the security right there
damn yep they could say security yeah
brother
guys i'm firing the kid and you guys
film it i'll film it 100
they you back again well [ __ ] i mean
apparently it'll be dope tell my girl
i'm going undercover she'll understand
it's weird because they show all those
big girls they get the real pretty girls
oh [ __ ] it's a fake one that was a tupac
audition for the movie
dude
tonight i bet you he got eaten a lot oh
you got a sage yes yes he did
he probably went home about five of them
all eyes on me
yeah all eyes on me yeah all right all
fries on me
as soon as you do that come on
that looks dope come with me
all right let's take a little break from
the shenanigans man
it's tough to find a massage these days
nobody's doing it you don't know what to
do
well i got you fam whether you're an
elite athlete you're just a regular
person trying to get through the day
with muscle pain you got that tension in
your legs cause you're always on the
bike
and you're all thick like me well guess
what that's why i got a theragon
the handheld therapy device that
releases your deepest
muscle tension listen some people
you you go to masseuse you don't need
any of that just get your girl or your
guy
you lay down let them go to work with
this gun they don't have to worry about
tying out their hands it's fantastic
there's an all-new generation four there
gun
all right it has a brushless motor
that's so quiet you wonder if it's even
on but you know it's on because you're
feeling
good all right try theragun for 30 days
there's no substitute for the third gun
generation 4
with an oled screen personalized airgun
app
and a quiet and power you need start at
only 199 dollars starting at only 199
dollars
go to theragan.com fighter right now and
get your generation four star gun today
that's thera gun t-h-e-r-a
gun dot-com fighter theragan.com fighter
guess what now's the time to get your
student loan payments under control
fam you could save crazy money by
refinancing your student loans with
earnest
nobody likes these high loans man so
lower your monthly payment right now it
takes just
two minutes all right interest rates
have hit
record lows which means it's a great
time to look into it
and refinance your student loan so you
can lower your monthly
payment if you've been making the same
monthly payments on your student loans
for the last couple of years
odds are you can crazily reduce your
payment i say crazily
all right even if you refinanced before
we got you man with today's low
rate you can refinance again check your
new rate is fast it's easy
to start complete a few quick questions
online takes two minutes
then you get a personalized rate
estimate without affecting your freaking
credit score
all right plus there's no uh
organization fee
or any other fees plus the internet
loves earnest customer service the rated
9.4 out of 10
on trustpilot and now you guys can get a
100
cash bonus when you refinance a student
loan with earnest
dot com slash fighter terms conditions
apply
once again you get a hundred dollars
cash bonus
when you visit earnest.com fighter to
refinance your student loan
it's not available in all states terms
and conditions apply visit earnest.com
fighter for more details terms
conditions apply earnest student loan
refinance loans are made
by earnest operations llc and mls da
number one two zero four nine one seven
california finance and law license
number 605-4788-303 2nd street suite 401
north san francisco california 94107
visit earnest.com license for full list
of license dates
shout out to club bounce wait real quick
uh going back to applebee's story
was she white of course i'm just curious
yeah
yeah okay what do you guys what are you
guys trying to say
curious just curious yeah it's tall
white girl it's all my girl
make got you drunk and took advantage of
you
i respect it sure i'm just saying
that's how you lost your virginity
respect it love perspective what you say
love is tight
love is gangster you're gonna love this
well um accidentally posted a topless
photo yesterday onto her
instagram story what do we got the
picture yeah i did
i did save it if you wanted to see it
hell yeah
hold on are those the biggest nipples in
the world that's the ariel
yeah areolas that's just a treasure
that's just a treasure map to the nipple
over there not the most flattering
picture right that's what she explained
she said that
she was looking on the camera and
something looks swollen
on camera but not in real life and so
she accidentally took
the photo to try to show offset yeah and
she accidentally pressed upload and it
started to load she couldn't try to
take it down yeah she turned off her
phone thinking it'll shut down yeah no
it ended up posting
and that she couldn't get back into her
phone cause she turned it off so it's
gonna take a couple minutes
she got somebody else who had her
instagram account on their phone to take
it off for her but by
the time she took it down it was ready
those are real huh those are real
no those titties aren't real i think her
tits are real her ass
really guys guys guys i've had my share
of titty
face i love it you see how you see how
there's markings on the areola oh you're
right
or right there's a she's she's under the
boot you see how there's like slashes
see how it looks like
she was like she's had multiple breast
surgeries you know my girl has
fake ones but now like yeah yeah okay
she'll say
the first time we were having sex
she was like you're not going to ask me
about uh like
and i was like oh i thought you had i
thought she had heart surgery
yeah i was like i just didn't want to i
didn't want to ask it was on the left
for the right titty
uh it was both i thought it was like oh
she probably had heart surgery oh so you
don't want to talk about it yeah i don't
want to talk
god bless you i know right i like fake
titties i prefer
they kind of like but some of them are
hard though
what type you get there are there's like
different types yeah there's one that's
like basically like so there's silicone
there's gummy and then there's one
that's like just basically water
the gut
oh yeah you're right looking at that
wait wait i do not post
wait i did not post she's fine i like
her more how she [ __ ] up
i think that she doesn't give a [ __ ]
when she does she's like oh what happens
here she's so bad
honestly we're an offsetter back to you
wait her booty her booty's fake yes
really yeah she got um she talked about
it before she got ass shots
before it's not like they put the
[ __ ]
they put the fat into it it's kind of a
brazilian butt lift where they insert
fat into the ass cheeks yeah
but why why that big why not i mean okay
uh in an interview she said that she
needed it that big when she first
started stripping because that's how she
would get more money just like
the more uh money you would end up doing
is nicki minaj is fake too
yes absolutely god bless you why
don't worry about it we'll talk later
yeah oh hers is too much for me
like it's a lot to like in an anaconda
video
man no don't get me wrong she's fine as
[ __ ] okay
yeah wait what are you doing so what are
you saying right now yeah
all right people think my girl and and
uh her mom's ass
is fake all the time like we'll be
walking through the mall and you'll see
i'll see people like whispering this
fake and i just went like it's real
yeah it's real oh really it's like i
mean you guys see my girl it's [ __ ] i
have a big ass i get it from my mom
oh okay well she was young there i like
she's young how old is she
uh i think she just recently turned 28.
oh she's in her 20s she's my age
oh okay she's young uh because the
kardashians have fake booties too
yeah like kim's is getting a little dumb
but they they
see that she's short it's a little dumpy
but but
she's the pioneer of fake ass so of
course her run is going to air out but i
mean it still look good
can we be honest when she got with kanye
she started dressing better and started
looking better now you know he dresses
that's all i know i know that's what my
girl told me
come on that's her baby that's really
her yep no that's not photoshop nope
i know you're here hell yeah dude do
it girl i'm not saying she can't i
didn't say that
what do you mean by a little droopy you
ever well it's like you said dumb it's
dumb puppy like it gets happy
oh so when you oh that's what you're
talking about it starts to like just
like gravity over time yeah like
it's like dude can only hold this for so
long who else out there celebrity with
fake ass
kylie jenner iggy azalea you see what
i'm saying a little dumpy
but you see how the quads don't match
the cheeks yeah it looks a little dumpy
who is that she's like
now again sign me the [ __ ] out like a
great i'm not mad at it dude
i'm not mad that matters do you ever
hear our boy stevie blue eye story
he had this he had this axe i couldn't
stand her he told me
so he he flies in miami pays for the
whole [ __ ] get-up
tits ass she and he's like all right
well you're going to recover i'm going
to go back to vegas you're good she goes
yeah i'll see you in vegas
dumped them oh back it up now she's with
a real famous oh
stevie
stevie root's against him and you guys
can figure out stevie's probably happy
right now because the guy got hurt
he got hurt oh oh i don't like oh
holy crap it's they won't figure it out
don't worry about it no because somebody
got somebody got hurt and i'm trying to
figure it out wait i'm going to catch up
you catch up
help me out come on you're talking to a
guy that [ __ ] reads books in the
morning
come on cut me out you just hit me come
on
okay bro you can be like self-help every
day though
yes how much help you need a lot
[ __ ] i was crazy
[ __ ] i mean every day you
every day yeah i don't want to go do it
it's work every day i don't [ __ ]
punch anybody anymore what are you going
to punch on over everything's all good
now i know
well i want to keep it that way you flip
out in here i don't right
i love how you say like how
yeah you know uh no i know immediately
but anyways
help me out stevie's girl i you know
famous quarterback
what's up what's the number oh
there you go really why are we just
gonna say that
i i want to hear people's laundry out
who knows what that guy is going on at
home oh i got your mom
if you know you know yeah if you know
you know but no bottom line she did my
boy stevie dirty yeah yeah yeah paid for
the whole get up she went
thanks dude i'm gonna get me a better
man
can't find a better man well
well i mean the game is the game though
she belongs to the streets
she belongs to the streets as you stand
world star she blinds the streets
yeah i love how you try to bring a world
star in that fight like recent quotes
well they didn't work they always had
well no world star like they posted this
this girl uh her husband walked in on
getting [ __ ] by
like her homie or his homie it says she
belongs on the streets i'm like
say less that's all he said to her well
no that's what they titled them
oh gotta go so she belongs the streets
on it belongs the streets click on
they're gonna fight oh that makes sense
did they fight oh dude the video shuts
off he's like what the [ __ ] the video
shuts off
wait so wait the dude was recording like
him he's smacking on his homies girl the
the dude heard it and
he's like you can hear like moaning and
he's like look at this [ __ ] opens the
door
and it's homies like oh [ __ ] why would
he record that though that's not a homie
that's not a homie at all why would you
record like uh my my girl getting
pounded
the phone is all [ __ ] up
that's the that's the culture we live in
now these [ __ ] dummies are like i'm
gonna put this on the ground
because it's like what did it do to
embarrass her he's trying to embarrass
like yeah
and you and you look like a cornball you
look even more like that
how is that embarrassing what is she
yeah no because it doesn't matter
in her life no it did not it didn't help
it may hurt in hell but still
i know what are you but for what you
blood crap you're putting your are you
putting your best
while no one gives a [ __ ] hey it's not
me dude i don't know what to do
i've heard of people doing that uh for
divorce settlements too like they know
they're going to leave their partner
but they want to catch them in the act
so they get more correct
but why would you put on social media
why don't you just take it to the court
um no she said they want to get more
well like for
like a video here here's what i'm saying
here's a good example like my boy tito
ortiz when he was dating
jameson i'm not saying anything that's
not out in the media already that he's
talked about
but they were going through a nasty uh
divorce right and have kids
and he was like dude she's not a fit mom
she's doing drugs around the kids
it's not safe and so he had cameras all
around the house
well she took the cameras down like d
wired him
so he let he made it look like they were
d wired but they weren't he went through
the back
and rewired them but he left the wires
look like they're broken
so then you know she's around the kid
and she has cocaine on the table she's
doing drugs
so he took that to court like [ __ ]
told you and now
he's great with his kids yeah the best
yeah so now he has full custody of the
kids
so that's an example yeah yeah yeah but
it didn't that didn't end up on world
star
yeah i think mal's point is just why is
that guy putting on yeah why is he
putting
decided to look at take that and put it
on there i don't think he sent the world
so i was like check this out
i don't know how world star works i
think it's just people who submit it you
don't know exactly
look yeah but he was probably just
trying to embarrass her like yeah look
at this that's what i'm saying probably
he probably could have texted homie and
be like yo look what i caught look look
no yeah someone could have sent that to
world star but i think world star has to
know
you have to sign off on it right yeah
exactly you have to sign up
yeah corny that's why i just stay away
from that that's why
food's going wild is my page that's nice
that's scary
verify them we'll start in barstool
all right next one so this is
unfortunate but uh do you remember
i would i think it was like a year or
two ago there was somebody putting like
needles into strawberries
at the grocery stores it's happening
again some guy got arrested because he
started to put razor blades into pizza
dough
uh he works out of a factory in maine
and that's where they found the pizza
dough with razor blades
but he tried to leave and he escaped to
new hampshire they ended up arresting
him
isn't that crazy wow like why would
anyone want to do this
sorry to interrupt scroll up chin right
there duncan don'ts employee arrested
after cop finds large
thick piece of mucus in his coffee
mucus oh that'd be a lookie yeah
someone's absolutely in his [ __ ]
coffee and a cop's coffee
but also that's a real naked choke it
might be something else
oh you think he busted his coffee it
could be not enough time not enough time
for coffee on whoever is pretty quick
i've made coffee i used to work at a i
used to work at a
room service oh i've been going crazy
that's crazy
but yeah so with this guy putting like
razor blades that's him
yep that's him he looks like yeah he
looks bad damn bro you could have done
you could have been better in life
if he just would have some self-help
books that's what i'm saying with you
buck
i sent him a few books to help him out
you know
hopefully you recover hopefully you
recover man but what is the point so
what was his excuse i know that
when you get caught why did you do it
because you're not going to know who
does it like that
my homie watches i think it's the
dateline [ __ ] or whatever
there was this case where uh how to
catch a predator no this dude
this dude uh sorry got his wife like
sick
and he went to go get her medication but
like prior he had did something to the
medic
medication like it was like the weirdest
[ __ ] he went through this whole like
back way to like you know [ __ ] with the
medication so it like ends up
killing yourself for life insurance oh
yeah [ __ ] like that what the [ __ ]
crazy people dude people are [ __ ]
nuts how to catch a predator it was a
good show
i love that i love this now you got to
watch dads against predators what's that
yeah i think
dabs against predators yeah it's on
youtube
what is that it's kind of like catch
predator a little more street oh they
got hood dudes in there
oh no you're just saying i mean more
gorilla style not so well done
there's no budget no producer it's on a
cell phone
but they'll pretend they're like a young
girl and a group chat or a young boy
and then they they're like oh meet us
here and then finally do it and they
roll up like what's up man you're
looking for timmy
i'm like oh [ __ ] and then they show the
text they had between them
who's still naming their kid timmy well
that's just a reference oh got it shout
out to me turner oh yeah i think he's
called daps dad's against predators it's
pretty dope do they get beat up at the
end
no it's rare they just out them so they
so that hopefully they do better
oh man it'd be hard to end with like a
[ __ ] because that's that's sick
local law enforcement asked dapps to
stop
wait where where do you see that news
report
we have not just been sitting back and
allowing these things to happen
law enforcement speaking out tonight
after a story that we first brought you
last night on action news at 11. this
youtube
video has been viewed tens of thousands
of times
it shows vigilante dads catching a
suspected child
predator at the fremont walmart they're
like batman
dads against so they're going to they
going to these walmarts
no no wherever come
whatever predator it is they're like oh
can you meet here and then the predator
be like yeah meet me here and then
the dad the dad because they're dads and
like you piece of [ __ ] and they just
film it
oh [ __ ] it's dope they're doing the
lord's work i'm gonna try that out
because that kind of kid's predator that
was just so we have not just been
sitting back allowing these things to
happen the video shows bill
dad's catching predator all right look
at that county
well look at the name of the county
right crazy
all are coming together ask the group to
stop why they're outing these [ __ ]
predators
i i i mean the only reason why i could
think of them asking them to stop
is for their safety you think
i don't know these dads are down to
fight too oh they're down
yeah it's dude if i found out someone
was touching kids i'd be super down
they're down to fight
[ __ ] yeah if you have kids you do not
yeah they're probably strapped too
you wanna hear the police say something
about it sure what because why would you
want them to stop
i'm guessing because they're taking over
the policeman's job maybe doing these
types of things
they're gonna stir up a hornet's nest
and all they're really do is exposing
these people
maybe embarrassing them and then they
walk free the group claims oh they want
to like
catch these [ __ ] but but if the
walk free what if if they
uh disclose the information to you why
won't you arrest them
good point i mean well is texting
illegal
no not really well they're intentions
yeah because it's less than a minor
right so yeah if you're saying pictures
dick pics or whatever it is to minors
that's against the law
yeah and they have all that footage like
i watched one dad
he was like the guy was like i'm gonna
call the cops he's like i'll call him
i'll call i was gonna call him but you
call him
we'll get him here and i'll show him
these texts and see what happens yeah
they're doing the lord's work i support
him support him shout out to uh
i'm down to go on
yeah i was i was on ghost adventures you
were on that yeah what do you mean were
you really yes are you
terrified dude you had to be where'd you
go i was in this haunted mansion in
denver
they have this one in kentucky that's
real scary oh they have a ghost
dude
really there you are no
it's not you yeah it is
bro you tripping i was so scared i'm
joined by ufc fighter brendan job
i was so scared oh yeah 100 look at
brendan
i just repeat everything they say one of
us
it was so dark down there and there was
a girl
there was a girl murdered down there oh
this is seeing this episode on lovecraft
country
watch it this is also at two in the
morning yeah
[ __ ] that brendan how long were you
there for
about hours dude they left me by myself
down there
where i live was so scared you could
look this up um
where i lived in athens texas it was
like
like one of like the top most satanic uh
towns in like america and uh they had
this thing
it's called fuller's park what i just
thinking of alex terrible story
oh you did
have your girl thinking about better
than malik okay
look it up look up at this texas like
satanic
no i'm not at most atmos is a dope-ass
brand athens
athens i know there's athens
georgia yeah there's like a monkey's
bridge there's thing called fuller's
park
they tore it down because there's like
this guy named reverend fuller
this is people have like satanic rituals
in this park
huh it's been years since i've been
there uh what about it doug
but it was just like uh i mean i went to
that fuller's park one time at night
yeah it was so scary oh my gosh i like
that was like i can't do [ __ ] like this
i did it once and i was like i don't
need to do it again again i don't know
if ghost adventures is real or fake i'm
not saying it's fake
i don't know if it's real but when i was
there that [ __ ] was so real yeah
yeah i was so scared and they're like
what was that building called
i forget but they're like the the ghost
stopped responding man so
we're gonna go upstairs it might be
better if you're just by yourself what
what what and like so we'll just leave
you down here like oh okay i was trying
to be tough in front of the cameras like
that sounds cool
and i'm like where'd the girl get
murdered like right there she's buried
right there she'll just
sit there so you're in this in this dirt
basement where this
literally a person was murdered and
buried there she was raped and murdered
and killed down there
so then they buried her there so i'm
sitting there by myself i was so scared
what about
like an hour how was you sitting indian
stuff i was on my knees
i was like man i was so scared dude my
brother came with me
jay yeah because i because i told zach i
went hey let me know if you want me to
do a show i'm down i love that stuff and
i do love that stuff
my mom's obsessed with it so really when
they called me i'm like oh i'm down and
i was so scared so and then i called my
brother at one in the morning like hey i
need you to come with me he's like
[ __ ] you gotta pick him up
is that is that like is that near where
you guys grew up pretty close yeah
well that's that's straight downtown
that's by like coors field and stuff
and then wait didn't that one thing
happen in denver
uh benay oh yeah that wasn't
that's where i lived oh you oh no you're
talking about jonbenet ramsay
yeah that happened in boulder where i
went to college oh god i got it got it
would you do that show again oh yeah you
would yeah i love zach
would you love to do i'm from louisiana
we they believe in voodoo and stuff like
that
i i went to the voodoo list yeah i'll do
it
oh [ __ ] i would not i would like it i
was so much fun too i was scared was so
fun
i'll pass i like i like that haunted
like scary stuff
yeah zach's on like i don't know season
30 or some [ __ ] oh really yeah
he kills it dude he's oh he's a great
guy fight pass
you know what what's it what's on face
puts this oh he watches fights i teamed
up
to bring you the throw of freaky fights
oh that's cool oh so you have seen
fights and ghosts
no i think just like you know for like
halloween probably
yeah wait how many squeezes is he on i
don't know but he crushes it dude
dude that's you know yeah i'll pass on
that come to death bro
all of a sudden he listens to this and
asks us all to come on he's a great dude
yeah it's so much 23 seasons dude 23
seasons
jesus did you do it would you guys ghost
adventure season you're doing that you
guys were here
you
what about you chin yeah of course i
think if the whole squad will do it you
have to do it man you kiss my ass too
many people
yeah many people wait wait wait i
thought it was a group it's like like
wait no it's just hard pass now we got
split up like the movies
well no no no no no i'm not doing that i
thought it was like a collective
i didn't know who's doing the joe exotic
zoo
23 all the ghosts of the tigers is
coming up you'll find out about carol
with carol baskin
i'll tell you what's weird is like i did
i did um
i did ghost adventures i did mythbusters
i do ridiculousness right i do
i'm shooting ridiculousness tomorrow
three episodes copied
that stuff's old then people will see it
for the first time so i'll get like dms
or emails
from ghost adventures from [ __ ] 10
years ago be like dude was it scary i'm
like
what it was 10 years ago man yeah but
they air it you know i don't know when
they [ __ ] yeah they just air it
well that stuff like those kind of shows
are just constantly like hey you look
way different now so i'm trying to
figure out
come on yeah he's not skin-headed season
19.
i've had some work done on my face yeah
you have no i wish i was about to say i
was like would you ever get work done
never oh love your face just gotta let
yeah
love your face yeah love your face you
look good what else you got jen
uh this right here kanye west you know
joe rogan and kanye west i guess kanye's
team whatever reached out to jeroboam
before like they might go on
so kanye's tweeting that he wants to go
on now but the funny thing about this
tweet is he says he's in calabasas
jerome and calabasas does he just not i
know
to date with the news but he could fly
to austin in the problem
yeah so he wants to go on now i would
love for
connie to be on there it's just
tough because the great thing about
rogan i think when people
like he doesn't entertain [ __ ] he
does so kanye comes on there and tries
taking over like he did with trump
remember we went on tr and just which is
impossible to do i think kanye's the
only person in the world who can do it
remember he just took over with trump
and trump let him run rogan won't let
you run he's gonna call you on your
[ __ ] so if
connie's talking about coming up with
his own [ __ ] encyclopedia and
dictionary
rogan's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah so
i would love to see it i'm a huge kanye
fan
i don't like that he's gotten so
religious he and his music's gotten
shittier but
i i like what kind let him love god man
let him love it yeah but
make better music you know well his new
stuff god wants to make better music
his new stuff his snippets have been fun
and i haven't been feeling his shoe game
like the yeezys at all lately
yeah i agree i agree with you on that
but uh his new music is fire
but how [ __ ] big is broken now
big trump tweets to come on kanye west
tweets it comes that's how big
the plastic [ __ ] i tweeted go i'll all
[ __ ] wait name a bigger show he'll
reply maybe with more ratings maybe
tucker carl
carlson because the debates right now
other than that
name a bigger show like you know i'm
talking about consistent consistent for
years yeah name a bigger show than joe
roger
everyone's like are you just saying
because your friend no [ __ ]
bigger than howard he's way bigger than
howard yeah not at least
oh yeah wow
howard last time i listened to howard
[ __ ] on seriously him coming at me
well you said really howard but it's
like who's listening to siriusxm
unless you're really listening to rogan
on itunes spotify
i mean but also at the same time like i
don't listen to a lot of rogan episodes
i mean the more recent one that i've
listened to [ __ ] man
i know i'm sorry sorry joe sorry joe you
have a team about me i don't [ __ ] with
rogan no i didn't say that i didn't say
that no
joey uh one of the ones that i
really like that he did was uh the one
he did with daryl davis
i thought that was a really great uh
white supremacist the guy that
got uh one two years ago no it was not
it was about a year ago about a year ago
that was over the summer because i was
texting joe about it i think so dude
you know look at that channel that was
not that was not during covent can you
give me something over
it was a little bit before covenant six
months ago
is it two you said two what did you say
no i i'm gonna say it was a year ago a
year ago what did you say daryl davis
you said episode 14 january 30th 2020
thank you very much february march april
may june july august
eight months ago september october
so we're in the middle all right we're
in the middle i respect it you know what
that was the last one you listened to
though a year or eight months oh no no
uh
rob funches i watched that one and uh
you watched kevin hart one
i watched it no okay i saw his first you
didn't watch oh henry the henry rollins
ones which
of course come on we should get henry
that's we should get henry on here can
we do that
i would be well i bet i could get them
on here man you know how big
i know i'm worried about it no no i
wouldn't you didn't be all hard
no yeah i mean i know i think he don't
take pills
no i would dude that would be phenomenal
i got to do it i got to perform with him
i got a picture with him on my ig it's a
great picture i've been following that
any guess you guys think about you want
to get on let us know
listen yeah justin's got to be here
justin's got to be here go there's
scroll hey
go go up that's the picture of me and
burr when i was working at the hotel
yeah yeah oh man you look like a grace a
law abiding
you look like you play golf look at this
yeah look at your pal i got all my pins
and stuff
oh my god you do have a bunch of pins
you don't need that many times
you do i was like i had anxiety uh when
i filled out the and that was when he
let me open for him
all right uh
yeah i think bill burr is the best com
comic in life oh come on alive
stop messing around there it is yeah me
and henry right there
that was dude that was you forced him to
take that picture yeah
dude our trailers were uh connected what
were you doing
uh we did this uh music festival that's
tom morello
um yeah you know stance just came out
with rage against the machine socks
i thought about it yeah that's brody
dale from the distillers
so that's pat smear from foo fighters
germs everyone's real
nirvana as well so
yeah i'm a big geek look at me i love it
i would geek too
one of those things for me yeah as far
as like
what's helped me like develop my brain
just listening to his stuff
you know he'll uh like he's not a
stand-up comic but he does like
spoken words yeah yeah he'll go when we
when we will go for four hours yeah i've
seen those
five hour shows i've seen this weekend
literally the here's and here's the wild
thing about it what
people sit through that and they [ __ ]
you you're just there and you're
you gotta be a super fan not even now
you walked out of hamilton yeah i walked
out of hamilton
yeah yeah
it's a two and a half hour play it's not
they tell you that it's first of all
it's
damn near four there's an intermediate
mission i went by myself i was out there
shooting a bravo show and i'm like i
have nothing to do i have the day off
night off
i was like i'll go buy tickets to
[ __ ] hamilton uh
homie hooked me up like through showtime
got me tickets i was good this is dope
so i go right and i'm sitting in the
chairs so i'm like it's very
uncomfortable i'm uncomfortable i'm like
oh this is
cool and like they just rap the whole
time though this is they're just
and you're not asking questions like
that you're not asking questions he did
not do that
he did not do that
that white guy's gonna rap brother
people so serious about their goddamn
plays
dude i dressed up i was looking fly
dressed up too all right so i'm chilling
there hour and a half
i'm like oh [ __ ] was that was cool man
that was dope and then
we go and they're like it's intermission
i'm like what yeah
we got another hour and like 90 minutes
uh-uh
oh you [ __ ] pissed out oh dude i'm
what i sat back down and sorry i went
i'm starving i'm gonna leave
so i'm walking out in new york in new
off-broadway yeah
and i'm walking out and the security
guys knew me right i took pictures
before i'm like you're leaving man
i was like i was like dog when i'm
starving they went
you're the first person to walk ever
hamilton ever though yeah
but you know i'd probably be right there
with you no you when i can't i checked
them
oh you wouldn't tell you like that you
don't check the box the accident
no
earlier that day i was starving yeah and
it's like once you see it all
two hours in here yeah that's what i
said i can't sit through stuff like that
hey type in
um uh beetlejuice be the juice wasn't
that long it was like
yeah the music yeah dude 2 hours and 45
minutes yeah
and i didn't know it was all rapping oh
you know there it is right there i mean
it was rapping and they ended on time
and it's the whole thing it's not like
sections they wrapped the entire
entire like the first after about 20
minutes i was like
oh [ __ ] they're gonna wrap this the
entire time i'm out
and i left i mean i've watched the foo
fighters play for like three hours
different i can listen like dave
matthews oh yeah
drake i could listen to you ever seen
drake live
the best performance i've ever seen dude
travis scott got drake drake was joking
you have seen eminem live i haven't i've
seen jay-z dope
there's just a lot of guys on stage oh
there it is a bummer
no d12 yeah yeah yeah the 12 days they
were on stage
like oh i didn't pay to see them all
right one of my favorites
john mayer oh he's great that
[ __ ] you know he's grateful dead
now
uh dead in company but
yeah you know what i'm talking about
though i thought
i didn't know about this
but they're dead in companies
grateful dead i love them you know you
know john mayer as far as celebrities go
has the greatest watch collection of any
celebrity oh yeah he goes
he talked to i think uh he talked with
dean del rey about it because dean del
rey
watch guy yeah he's a watch guys maybe
we should get dean on it me and dean got
a lot in common i talked about time when
we're at the store because
dean likes watches and cars especially
porsches yeah i mean him always talk
about that
he has the greatest watch like if you're
a watch guy he has the greatest
collection
ever that's actually really that's adobe
i don't [ __ ] with watches i'm about to
get a rogue i like that one
do you want to watch this [ __ ] i i do i
just lost them
obsessed with watching yeah that's the
weirdest [ __ ] my
it's not they're kind of like to me
they're kind of like trophies like my my
most
like ride or die watch is that that
submariner um
rolex the the gold one cause i i bought
that i bought it used but i bought that
when uh firing the kid 3d when we went
number one on itunes we beat out amy
schumer
we beat out uh tosh poino we went number
one oh really and i got
money from that like an idiot i paid
basically half my money for that watch
do what you got to do no hell no he was
happy
i'm just trying to get a honda what i'm
trying to get oyster perpetual
but the thing about that is uh kind of
fox like made it so difficult on us and
they think you'd do well
and within a week they got their money
back oh really yeah
it yeah that's why we can't oh that
makes boxer owns it but they kind of bet
against us so when it went number one i
was like [ __ ] y'all yeah
shut up the next day that's the watch
you got that's the watch i had i lost oh
wait what oh you have that diamond
bretlane super what
but it costs like three hundred dollars
for a fake one but i didn't have the
time better
but this is my dream real cost it's like
five or six thousand dollars it's not
crazy for a watch
but still it's it's a chunky one yeah
what did you pay for that one watch for
that gold rolex yeah
he's like don't make me see i see what
you i see what you think it's like 16.
16. and that's used
yeah it was used i'm about to get the
oyster perpetual always
perpetual what the hell is that melon
chin scroll down
that one's only not only but for what it
is that's one's 4 400. i think it's used
i think it's a pre-owned
dude i'm telling you if you want a nice
use is the way to go you don't
like bob's watches or something that's
the best place
you never buy them new never i mean i'm
gonna get on team rogue and get the
whoop
[Music]
bracelet trick
find it
oh for real yeah can i have it i've been
[ __ ] with way before all that was a
sincere question all right i i i really
want it can you get
in the car yeah oh that's the greatest
yeah get everything subscription yeah
i don't know i want to roll it i don't
know 10 bucks oh you just go find like a
netflix thing
for it i'm totally done have your girl
by your chinese rolex
we in a car today you watch oh yeah oh
yeah congratulations
yeah let's let us cruise the car yeah
the cruiser
oh she let you take the whip yeah but
she didn't give us the good whip she
just gave us
yeah you act really good what else you
got jen i did a bad transition by the
way you guys talking about ghosts and
everything
i skipped over a cat's uh current event
this one here
oh yeah there's a tour a canadian
tourist who uh
went to pompeii when she was like 21
years old she wanted a piece of history
from there
that she said she couldn't like you
couldn't buy and so she stole
different artifacts from the land she
says that she's certain she was cursed
for 15 years
she had breast cancer twice had a double
mastectomy
she ended up actually sending those
things
back to the museum in pompei and
basically apologizing
saying that she didn't know what taking
those artifacts would entail
and she didn't she doesn't want the bad
luck anymore she doesn't want to pass it
on
to her kids and so she's trying to
return it hoping that her luck
goes back to normal she goes she goes
the the last time
ending in a double mastectomy my family
isil
suffered financial problems we're good
people and i don't want to pass this
curse along to my family or children
and the head of the museum says that a
lot of people do that where they take
[ __ ] and then they end up mailing it
back because they have so much bad luck
like it's not uh
well you're just not supposed to steal
yeah yeah [ __ ] she goes we took them
down and dash
we got money at the time
[ __ ] took something from the the the
victims of
the pompeii i don't steal from the
museum i had a horrible death in
fire and i saw them hell no it wasn't
good we took them out thinking of the
pain suffering these poor souls
experienced during the eruption of
uh in a terrible death wow
wow over the years so many stolen relics
have been returned to the site
along with expressing guilt wow well
just don't do that
well you don't know what people are
going through i still
well you didn't steal well i'll have
enough i don't have enough money go to
pape
pompey pompeo you don't have enough
money to pronounce it
if you're queen of flight well i
wouldn't have to steal if my queen if
she can fly me i can buy that
no she could buy it for you okay i don't
think you can buy this stuff though
that's not you sure
you sure you can buy artifacts from pay
i don't think so being an
[ __ ] and taking that why do you need
that let it be where it is
yeah why do you need that she learned
the hard way she said she wanted a piece
of history that you couldn't buy
that now that's that's the wrong [ __ ]
though exactly like i don't want i don't
want to change like i mean
yeah i don't want that [ __ ]
come on come on bro you guys remember
that brady bunch episode it's kind of
simple
now they took something from hawaiian
secrets
and then they were like cursed as well
i've been uh by the
brady bunch house multiple times where's
that studio city
there's yeah there's security there uh
the whole time oh really yep
but i didn't they i went for sale
recently i think no i did not
really still there i think the house
from full house was on sale a couple
years ago
oh it's full of the house now oh really
yes oh netflix fuller house
what about the house uh uh we're um
fresh prince oh belle airbnb
yeah it's in brentwood right now because
they're doing the 30th anniversary
they're doing a reunion
episode they're actually renting it out
for
i think it's not very expensive like
less than a hundred dollars a night it's
renting out at the airbnb
we can do that we can get it rp uncle
field we can do that yeah it's out of
brentwood
yeah just right here
this one right here everyone has seen
this by now right oh my gosh dude
this was dope yeah cougar a guy was
going jogging right this guy but here is
my thing
why is this guy so friendly in this
[ __ ] cougar why would you take a
[ __ ] rock
and hit him in this software juicy nose
i thought that too but i'm thinking like
am i gonna when you squat i mean they're
they're really yeah
that's one thing to do like if you what
if you aggravate him too he's like he's
just kind of trying to scare you but
then you throw something at him then he
just
comes at you no the the throwing would
scare him but like
it's just there i don't like how
friendly it was like come on bro ah
you gotta act big you gotta like my bad
i thought you was talking about an older
one you haven't seen this
i apologize i didn't know y'all talking
about an animal
it's six minutes it's so long but then
you can kind of see like give me the
skill parts
he comes at him for at first though he
was walking jogging across and saw like
two baby cougars
and then out of nowhere the mother comes
out like he's like oh [ __ ]
she was just protecting her that's why
that's probably why she ran back though
definitely but wait i think i'm an
animal enthusiast
is that the word but look how friendly
he is though yeah no
why he just didn't start running you
cannot run around you can't run
you can't you can't turn your back i
don't think you that's
what a stupid
oh [ __ ] you see that he started going
out wait let me see one right there oh
he starts going like this that is so
fast he's flying that's what i'm saying
if he picked up a rock yeah it's not a
big he has to be real quick
he could have picked up a rock a long
time ago
brandon you act like you know what you
would have been been able to really you
know
i would have pegged that [ __ ]
real talk when they get hit yeah they do
like you know
they don't like it yeah they retreat
yeah have you seen him like you ever
seen a lion like
even barely get kicked or anything yeah
they hate it they hate it so they take
off
either you're surrounded by rocks you
take that [ __ ] rock and you nolan
ryan that thing in the stupid nose
you gotta get out you gotta aim like
that i'm gonna scare the [ __ ] out yeah
i'm gonna hit him but what have you
missed
well he's not gonna like it though he's
like oh [ __ ] no
this guy was too this guy was such a fan
he stalked him for six minutes well he
didn't want to hurt it
he was like a friendly vegan bro he's
like come on man i'm a good person leave
me alone
yeah he was you show the picture of him
the part where he throws the rock at it
oh he's zipped
in a rock did he yeah watch that's how
it goes away you're kidding
yes what he did does it
watch you'll see and then it just starts
taking off oh so he's picking it right
there picking up right here
way too close i couldn't see him throw
it though
[ __ ] he called him a [ __ ] boy yeah i'll
talk [ __ ] out of the way
i got [ __ ] from him he called
i would keep going i wouldn't i know
exactly keep going
what did she come back with our homies
oh yeah
yeah but dude he was so smart not
turning his back
he was so smart about that i'd have been
out actually because they don't like to
fight
common sense i feel like who the [ __ ]
would turn them back on you panic
well i didn't know i mean i i got chased
in the hood without
more you know now yeah can you imagine
the [ __ ] rainbow that pops out the
more you know the more you if you're
walking backwards you can't see anything
and you trip
it's over well not it's over you don't
fall when i won't we don't really fall i
just see that in school
and stuff i just can't believe you
didn't pick it up like as soon as you
threw the rock that thing took off
yeah why would you wait six minutes to a
[ __ ] i honestly didn't know if that
would work so
at that moment i didn't know a rock
would work because i thought maybe i'm
aggravating it
up but now i'm gonna look into it [ __ ]
that thing so you all you gotta walk
back
yeah i don't believe them right now i'm
gonna figure it out later
well you know how they say get loud and
stuff those boys in uh washington
run that bike on a bike right now uh
mountain lion was stalking them
and so they decided to stop and get big
and bring up their bikes
like oh cool you guys are going to stop
very cool attacked both of them
was eating his buddy and his buddy goes
oh [ __ ] dude i'll go get help
takes off the mountain goes where the
[ __ ] do you leaves his friend
tackles that guy eats him alive and then
his friend got away
and then they went to find him and they
found the guy up in the tree and like
oh yeah because that's where they take
their that's real oh yeah killed the guy
that's a
can you imagine having someone believe
you 80 a year ago
a year ago yeah not that long ago
remember we had it was it out here
washington washington damn they're
saying this mountain lion was like
starving though that's when you get in
trouble if you're like starving like i
don't know so what do you do so
you throw the rock you got to do fight
what you don't do is run like his [ __ ]
ass friend was like oh dude good luck
and took off running the mountain lion's
like oh cool man i'm going to get you
and yeah yeah you wouldn't run in those
that's food
that's the thing that's so wild about it
they're just trying to eat yeah that's
how they have to eat and protect their
young yeah the protector you gotta eat
people think they're ruthless like no
they're not ruthless just [ __ ] hungry
hungry pretty ruthless they're gonna eat
you
[ __ ] they're gonna eat you dude yeah
cause they're hungry
so what would you do in the situation
what would you do no
oh they if they're not hungry they won't
[ __ ] with you i don't know dude if you
know the cubs or you stumble upon them
shane google that what
if they if they ain't hungry they ain't
going to eat you just put that in google
i think
[Laughter]
well that one said no he really wrote
does that help out what does it say it
doesn't say anymore
it says it says uh research suggests
that when they are hungry the cats throw
caution to the wind
yeah if they're hungry they're going to
[ __ ] try and eat you what else you
got jen
um your nba thing not there here
lois ravens ever recorded nba i knew you
was gonna bring this up
ever i'm just gonna bring this up can i
speak my piece
okay go ahead nobody gives a flying [ __ ]
that lebron won the finals oh well that
crazy
you know what you know what more people
watching sunday night football regular
season because
i didn't see many people post about it
what neither
i didn't see many posts you don't follow
people in l.a i think that i do i do
i mean i know they got crazy downtown
like i knew you know what you know what
i think it is i think
like the world's on fire and people have
so much more to worry about than sports
that they're just like dude who gives a
[ __ ] dude
are you people are still watching
football people are still watching
baseball the baseball are they small
ratings are down like a month but
but but they're still uh it's millions
they're not up
i looked at it last night it was
millions they're way down okay okay 40
percent
okay you just said you said people are
not watching sports no you gave us ufc
you said ufc sport that's a sport and
then ratings are high
so people are not bored they just like
yo this lebron james they knew this was
a mismatch
and what 5.6 million and they already
knew they was going to close out i
didn't really watch the game
it was a blowout and that was the last
game let's go to game two
it was a blowout i had stuff to do but
i'm saying in game two
they had nine point six is that a little
low rating
hmm i don't know it's not so i don't
know
so for instance minnesota vikings who
are terrible against seattle seahawks
drew up
twice as many viewers a regular season
it was a great game no
brilliant it was a great game all right
game where wilson came back
it went down to the wire
um so since for context last year's nba
finals game six between golden state and
toronto raptors delivered 18.3 when the
world was open
what did jordan get 36 million that's
when basketball that's one
that's when they were thriving that was
the key jordan yeah yeah that's one bad
he's like everyone loved jordan a lot of
people hate so lebron so
i think i think i think and i'm a lebron
fan
i just don't see him like it brendan i'm
i am a lebron fan he actually was riding
with you
the whole i like lebron i like lebron i
just think i
do think he's a little bit fake i think
the the
malcolm x with everything i don't think
anything's real that comes out of his
mouth i think
i think he's just saying it's an act i
think i think he thinks that's what the
public wants so he's doing it what do
you mean like when he speaks he's not
real
he's just not real no just like in
general like not like a specific genre
of topic no he's
just saying what he thinks everybody
wants to hear not really like also like
the goat conversation was like yeah and
i need my respect too it's like
what do you refer like they did an
interview after like are you referring
to jordan like you want to be known as
the goat he's like
no just in general it's like dude say
how you
feel well we know what you're talking
about he just put out a post today
and and uh by the way i liked it and he
goes on his instagram he was like
look i'll read it for you this thing
the same thing that you're addressing
like oh just tell speak how you feel
about everyone's bashing them and
criticizing them right there with the
smoke chain
read it can you zoom in it says up in
motor
what they gonna say now i know they make
up another criteria that nobody else has
ever had in the history of the game but
guess what though
bring it on heavy is the hand that holds
the king the crown they say
let's get a kid from aggregate what is
that what is that i'm not so
are you are you saying he's referring to
everyone best of all
like what are you talking about okay so
when he got hurt a lot of people when
they said oh he
came to la to make movies don't want to
win championships
oh he's just coming here to be michael b
jordan he's not trying to
chase michael jordan they uh we heard
all the rumors about like oh
uh he's he's not interested in
basketball he's not trump trying to win
the championship
and then when he got him that's just
noise well yeah he has nothing to do
with him
yeah that's what he's referring to he's
quick that's like he's done he's never
won the championship
again that's why he said revenge season
complete
so everything he said give me a d and
i'm gonna win you a championship give me
a d
give me one of the top five players in
the league and i'll win a champion so
the warriors
the warriors had kd i know i'm not
saying that's great either
okay okay they won without katie yeah
but that's the asterisk because lebron
james didn't have
kyrie irving or kevin yeah he didn't it
was hurting that championship series
they had i mean he had definitely no
golden state before yeah
and so he came back from 3-1 but listen
i'm not lebron hayden i think there's
more pressure on him than there were
any other player in the world correct my
problem for lebron is it's just
it's it's not authentic and everybody
can smell it
and that's why nobody tunes in you need
to be authentic but that's uh
it's the same thing with kaepernick it's
not authentic yeah
but um but but here's the thing that's
that's i don't think
i don't think people hate him for of
course speaking i just think they hate
do you have your jordan fans you have
your lebron james fans jordan
of course you don't like jordan i mean
he balls get out
we don't like michael jordan but this is
why that's what makes your argument
difficult then if you don't
like jordan i don't like jordan but i
respect but but this is the thing about
jordan is when they went
hey man why don't you take a side
politically with him and he goes because
republicans buy shoes too i don't give a
[ __ ] it's like
you might not agree with it be like oh
damn that's real like he was always real
i'm glad you brought that up so on the
last dance you saw the last dance
they asked him about the comment that he
made republicans uh buy
shoes too he was like i didn't i said in
a joking way i didn't mean it like as
far as
so he backtracked so is that fake
brendan well i don't think he
backtracked
i think he was like yeah that i was just
saying republicans like shoes too i
don't at the time didn't make it
but what he didn't do is come out and be
like you know i think all lives matter
and all the you know and you're like
what the [ __ ] are you talking lebron
never said that
no but when when lebron comes out it's
just not my problem with lebron is
nothing's authentic
okay so you can pick and choose when
human equality works for you so
you'll you'll make sure that space jam 2
works over in china but you won't stick
up for the
the chinese and what they're doing to
hong kong and when they ask you about it
because
that's not that's not my thing it's like
but it is your thing dude
you know i get which it's just not real
okay okay i think that's people's issue
with lebron james i guess
i agree with you on that i don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah i don't care yeah i like he's a
great basketball player
i think you know definitely top three of
all time if you wanna argue number one
all right cool dude if that's your guy
that's
fine i don't give a [ __ ] that's where
i'm at on it
i think he's great i think jordan's
great i think kobe is great i think
magic's great
oscar robinson is great i don't think
you can say who's the best because it's
different criteria like he's playing a
different time
the culture is different social medias
he's getting judged left and right every
move he makes is on video correct
dude i guarantee you wouldn't have the
same views of michael jordan social
media was around back then
he was 100 he's an [ __ ] he's a dick
so if that he's basically ellen who's
really good at basketball
straight up he was ellen basketball
that's a good comparison
yeah so so when you say that the ratings
are down it's not people hate lebron
i think people are like no fan you got
we're in a bubble
you're right we're in the bubble no fans
like i'm it's like the best product
that's a bad excuse because i think the
product look the best i've been to me i
think so but a lot of people like fans
they love the energy
i think middle america and americans in
general didn't like their stance
on protesting of the of trump and the
in the national anthem i think that
turned off a large majority of the
audience
i think lebron's stance turned a large
majority off i think they're in a bubble
i think they were favorite i think it's
lebron so i think you take
all that and raise all those [ __ ] well
but i'll agree with you but they have
that they have that in
the nfl nfl i saw it they have the black
lives matter on the back of their
helmets they have that
they somehow they're not protesting
games what do you mean and they're not
showing that they're not taking a neal
national anthem anymore you know that is
true
i give you that but the only thing they
had was black lives matter on the court
right and then on their jerseys on their
jerseys okay but but
and during press conferences it's only
like lebron for a while that's all i
talked about
and they didn't show up too right for a
little bit
not only did that show up they didn't
play games yes that's what i meant so
with america it's just tough man when
you're dealing with middle
middle america it's not that they're
racist they're like dude
just give us basketball right now man
like just let us watch basketball you
know
so and again i don't care if that's what
they want to do do it man if that's what
you believe in do it i'm still going to
watch
i don't care you can put whatever you
want to back your jerseys i don't care
you just saying medical medicine i think
a large majority of americans like
nah [ __ ] this man you know if you're you
know because a lot of them
they don't look into it they think it's
like anti-american dude you disrespect
the flag
it doesn't matter nfl look at the nfl
when they start taking a knee and colin
kaepernick ratings went [ __ ] tank
dude
they don't care americans do not you
disrespect america they do not play that
man
[ __ ] we see it well [ __ ] i mean again
i'm not saying them
protesting and doing their stuff is
wrong either
that's what you believe in [ __ ] do it
dude exactly that's america to me
like you have the right to do that
that's what makes this place great
exactly i'm still gonna watch it's still
well a lot of it pisses a lot of people
off but it's a democracy we live in a
democracy state and i think that like
you
you express your feeling no one wants to
see their own race get gunned down on
in the street right and and lebron
talking about that
and what people get you got to be
educated on if you're going exactly
but if you're going to get on that
platform yeah and and talk that talk you
better be educated on it and he wasn't
online and
he dropped the ball exactly i get you
but he had people it was like it was
like you do a news report
i studied it though i studied it my girl
i had another one today
have a great idea to add to the show too
is we do
uh the instagram of the week so you know
how we looked at that fat dude on the
scooter
yeah we looked at uh vin diesels
yeah so if you guys find some cool stuff
or funny stuff yeah is there a profile
he thinks funny
yeah we're getting a shout out too so
though oh yeah
vin diesel definitely needs our shout
out
i got i mean i gotta give a shout out
right now this dude did a
patrice o'neill uh digital painting for
me then i'm about to just point it out
this dude is much loved you guys ain't
doing shout outs on the podcast
all right so speaking of vin diesel he
posted this uh yeah 17 hours ago
damn i hate how it just plays
automatically though hold on
give me some volume dog hold up i'm
about to get lost in this voicemail
i can't wait
[Laughter]
how often do you think his family
listens to the song because he's
constantly
he says billboard charts so is he like
top of the charts yeah
he probably is how do you become like
talking where is it at on the track
i think there's a top hundred yeah we'll
check it out right now i think they have
different ones where it's like a hundred
and two hundred oh wow
that's still pretty good that's great
well yeah
so kygo is usually on billboards yeah
his fan base
uh is huge internationally too mm-hmm
i feel like asians love vin diesel yeah
yeah
i got a good little market over there
where's it at 1.1 million number 18.
it's top 10. oh my god it's top 10 son
i feel like i do wow bro should just
like lead out on that song top 10 on the
charts electric top 10. wow good bro
good feeling
because we keep talking about it on this
show yeah oh i [ __ ] love that i feel
like i do
we should come up with some stuff i
think that's why it keeps popping like
that
what else you guys got uh wait it's not
hard rock that's not the genre
wait is this a different one yeah it
must be come over here let me put vin
diesel wait
man i was about to say don't play my man
like that
so the one that we
number 18 it says bowing in at number
18.
either way dude just to make that's
really good i imagine him getting back
on fast and furious now i know he got a
number one hit
man i told you being upset
uh this one from bar stool i saw
oh yeah [ __ ] no you would never be able
to tell that this girl is kind of like
dropped off jacked hold on you
mean we wouldn't be able to tell yeah
like this jacked
she got a kangaroo body holy [ __ ]
damn the kangaroo in the shade her face
she looks pretty too yeah and this she's
from australia oh this is her yeah ellie
she's in north carolina is she what's
she look like when she's not
[ __ ] flexing her traps like a
stingray
those are those crossfit girls oh
she's like a different person yeah
what's her instagram
i hate when is it all workout videos
like i know something people love that
though
show me something else yeah that's a
good one oh okay
well she's a baddie yeah she is oh she
has some
tits in the first picture okay
knows what pictures to go to now he's
not going through these wholesome
pictures anymore she's pregnant
yeah her traps are tough uh so one last
one i thought this was cute
it's the little dog
doesn't even care oh wow
it looks like it seems something i know
and he was like bro you know who i come
home to you'll get this weird didn't
even get scared yeah
he probably over life right there said i
thought this is really cute yeah it's
cute it's adorable
yeah china always knows how to top it
off you know yeah is that it
that's it all right man uh dude you're
in tampa
yeah i'm in tampa see you guys tomorrow
morning there's sunday thursday friday
saturday
sunday chapelle lacey.com for those
tickets man we should show you the ocean
splitters dates to t k too yeah that'd
be dope
side splitters and he's there this
thursday friday saturday
and then this squad plus a surprise spot
by stevo himself
yes phoenix arizona stand up live
november 5th through the 7th
then we're in nashville november 19th
through the 21st
and then it's not on there right now but
we're adding boise doing a theater in
boise december 5th kids
these tickets be available soon also we
just restocked the thick boy jerseys
the south beach jersey and the green
donuts jersey those just came back
think boy.com uh that's it man we'll see
you kids
in uh next week and then we'll see you
can see chappelle in tampa you see the
rest of us in phoenix in nashville
thickboy.com let's go way out look at
them jerseys